. We have a new report out that seeks to answer
the question how many coronavirus deaths can
we really attribute to former President Donald
Trump?
And, you know, one of the things we knew intuitively
during the Trump presidency and which was
confirmed a number of times by different studies,
was that no president could have predicted
every coronavirus death.
No president could have even prevented rather
rather than predicted predicted is a different
thing.
No president could have prevented every coronavirus
death.
We were going to have many deaths as even
countries that dealt with the virus well had
many deaths.
But the lack of taking the virus seriously
by the Trump administration from day one certainly
was at least partially responsible for some
of the deaths.
A new report now says that 40 percent of the
deaths that took place in 2020 could have
been avoided if Trump had merely handled the
virus well enough for the U.S. to have the
same not not number of cases, but mortality
rate of other wealthy countries at our level
of development.
This study was published in The Lancet, one
of the oldest and best known medical journals,
and it explains that the U.S. had way more
deaths, a higher mortality rate during the
pandemic than other rich countries, countries,
including the UK and a number of other countries,
and that many of the cases and deaths were
avoidable.
They could have been avoided by the federal
government response being more serious from
the beginning, rolling out testing earlier
on, having stricter guidelines or at least
making it clear that they should be enforced
and that Donald Trump wanted to see those
enforced.
And unfortunately, some of these problems
date back even before Donald Trump.
We know that the United States, when it comes
to health care, even though we spend a ton
of money on health care, we often have worse
outcomes than many other wealthy developed
countries, Germany, Canada, UK, so on and
so forth.
And so part of this is a bigger problem than
Donald Trump.
A lot of our systems not interacting well,
federal and state not interacting well, so
on and so forth.
But then beyond that was the failed federal
response from Donald Trump.
And I think a lot of us intuitively understand
this.
The number of infections early, the lack of
just being realistic, the lack of letting
actual medical professionals guide the response.
And as I've said before, if indeed Donald
and we'll talk about this in a moment when
we talk about Joe Biden's approval rating,
if Donald Trump had simply said, what do doctors
think we should do, what do public health
experts think we should do?
Epidemiologists, immunologists, people who
know about this and aren't going to say things
like, would the flu vaccine work against coronavirus,
as Donald Trump did back in?
I don't remember if it was February or March,
many of these deaths would have been avoided.
And we now know that beyond any doubt whatsoever.
And the question now becomes, under new leadership,
can we do as well as other countries when
it comes to vaccine distribution and lowering
the mortality rate and keeping cases low if
and when we get them low?
So far, the numbers are cautiously optimistic.
We had a couple of days in the last week where
there were two million vaccinations done each
day.
If indeed we have a third vaccine approved
sometime in the near future, as it looks like
we will, it's not completely unreasonable
to think that we could get to a steady two
or 2.5 million vaccine doses per day.
And we.
These are not, you know, one of the saddest
things that has taken place during the pandemic.
Obviously the deaths and cases and economic
implications and psychological impact for
so many people have been terrible.
But one of the saddest things that that we've
also seen has been the realization that the
people in charge really do make a difference
what the politics are of your governor in
dealing with the pandemic.
It really makes a difference.
Whether there is a competent federal government
response really makes a difference when you
have people like Jared Kushner saying while
the stockpile is our stockpile, it's not for
the states.
That's just not a disgusting political statement
that you see on TV that has a real trickle
down impact.
And hopefully we're going to see that improve.
And it seems as though the American people
are confident that it is improving.
Joe Biden with the highest initial approval
rating in twenty eight years.
Let's talk about
that now.